we do indeed we are with Guru back into
his Genova beg him welcome back to the
show a win against the leader of the
tournament going in this round Megan Lee
how do you feel right now after such a
victory oh it feels amazing yesterday I
couldn't sleep after I lost the game so
I had to like I had to win it didn't
matter who I'm playing I just came to
win the game and
luckily I won this tournament especially
the ladies section is so topsy-turvy the
leadership position always changes what
is it about this event I think we are
not as
professional as a like men's section we
have like almost all of us has different
things that we do so we really don't
Focus maybe here in a crush she's the
only one who's and young girls or who
work on chess more but I'm a student too
so I can't feel others who do something
else in life that's why it's kind of
like that opens up the possibility for
more decisive results is what you're
saying yeah we are not stable I
understand okay let's talk about today's
game because it was quite tense and I
didn't really know what's happening in
the position how did you assess it I had
no clue after she played Knight E4
that's that's a weird move you usually
like everyone plays Castle so I decided
to just uh play something logical like
C4 Knight C3 it's it seems to me seems
like very logical and I need to just
develop my pieces and we'll see I I
thought she's gonna attack on C4 but
but it felt like my position was always
better and it was indeed taking on C4
was a bit uh dangerous yeah but she was
nervous I I do understand her situation
he's she's like uh she's trying not to
lose the game but she needs to score
some points as well that's why she
risked a little bit for no reason I
guess so you felt her being in the lead
puts extra pressure I mean you can even
see the way she's moving it's just like
she's writing down the most she was just
very nervous to play the game and you're
playing quite fast up to this point how
did you assess it especially at this
point okay an extra pound for her but
you do have your own compensation with
this attack coming on the inside yeah I
thought two Bishops okay I don't
understand she has extra pawn and I'm
not getting it back like
uh I don't know in a few months or
anytime soon right so I just said I'm
just gonna play the game and it feels
like her night is not that well placed
as well so I I had h4h5 ideas but I
thought I'm gonna develop and at some
point it just happens
and you ladies went into this she was
setting up some ideas of Knight ac5 you
define it with this move Queen to E3
that's so weird here I
have a feeling that I let her like go a
little bit maybe bishop B4 at some point
would be better
Let's uh take a look actually at this
point it seems like she is slightly
better yeah that's so weird because I I
felt like I did all the natural moves
and I ended up being not like even
better yes because it felt like I was
better and Bishop to E4 Knight to C7 uh
yeah I I wasn't happy about Bishop
before I thought it's the worst Square
because after Knight C7 she's
threatening like B4 and I cannot even
play Bishop D2 or something like that so
so for example if you go H4 B4 comes
yeah and then A6 is protected yeah yes
my plan was to attack on B4 with the
bishop so that's why maybe bishop B4
would be better for me than Bishop A3 at
some point
um maybe earlier right maybe here we
should be four uh unclear it does say
like okay seven yeah that actually
improves the opposition for uh black but
still very tense position at this point
and uh this felt like the critical
moment if H4 like H4 H5 was a good idea
but then I
like spotted that if she plays Knight E8
which is a very natural move she's just
losing after a d takes C5 yeah
I I thought she could miss it because
she was like she was in a Time trouble
that's why it was very hard to assess
the position it's so weird because if
you do something else you're kind of
okay you're holding the position well
only with this whole night yeah I
thought after 95 it's just equal yeah
but I wasn't sure if she's gonna give
away a poem
so you felt she was trying to because
she was trying to hold some chances of
winning the election that was that was
the thing I guess and she couldn't
assess after Knight D5 it seems like and
you found this idea with route D7 Bishop
to C6 which was critical and after that
converted a nice game began
congratulations uh right now you will be
one and a half points behind the leader
most likely Jennifer you going into the
last four uh what Ambitions are you
harboring about the last four rounds I I
I'm just trying to play like chess but
unfortunately I'm not playing well
that's why I just want to play I just
want to show some good games because it
was a disaster and I'm very upset about
my games so I don't I don't really care
about the results it's like I already
missed my chance I guess but I try to do
my best to end the tournament well guys
yeah just uh congratulations great great
game we really enjoyed it all the way
throughout Vegas and good luck in the
rest of the tournament absolutely we
enjoy watching you play and I don't know
Anastasia I think it's just time for